the trauma of war in a children's
hospital
this boy was hit by gunfire as russian
forces advanced on ukraine's capital
just 14 years old he suffered face back
and leg wounds three nights ago
his latest procedure described as minor
surgery
russia's invasion prompted medics to set
up this makeshift emergency department
three children have been brought in so
far including a ten-year-old who died on
route that was the quiet place
with just kids with the scheduled
operations
and now in one moment
it changes so okay this is war
two days ago we have the gun fights all
around the block with the artillery
fights etc etc
but this night was a little bit
cold so and
the war changes the priority
so now if you can take a shower and take
a coffee it is luxury
he's barely slept
as well as preparing to treat war
casualties he and his colleagues have an
equally vital job to do here in the
emergency department the doctors are
tired
they're worried about an influx of more
patients and they're also worried about
what to do with the very sick children
who are being treated in this hospital
before the war started the lights are
off
because of their
we should be like
nobody should see us
so we resolved life four-year-old nikita
has leukemia he receives chemotherapy
and blood transfusions the little boy
also has down syndrome but
usually
usually children
should not even be in the corridor the
noise you can hear is his teeth grinding
something he's done since russian
missiles started falling
this is where he should be treated but
his mother now has to shuttle up and
down from the basement where it's safer
for them to stay how are you feeling
dealing with all of this i'm sorry to us
you know trembling hands are trembling
um
legs like you're you are in fitness gym
because downstairs um 10 000 meters a
day
steps a day
up and down with children with bags
she wants to take him out of the country
but it's hard our children can't live
without hospital without medical
treatment
you know it's just a few days
and that's all so we should if we will
go to another country we should uh cross
uh the
border but with a doctor
they're not alone
other children dealt the same cruel
blows
fighting life-threatening disease in the
middle of a war zone and with russian
forces closing in on the capital
debrahing sky news